في عام 2015 ، قالت بعض المنافذ الإخبارية إننا سنكون بلا
سائق هذا العام ،
نعم ، لا يستطيع معظم الخبراء الاتفاق
على موعد وصول هذا المستقبل ،
لكن لديهم فكرة جيدة عن
كيفية عمله
سواء أكانت سيارات الأجرة الآلية حافلات ذاتية القيادة
أو دراجات بخارية كهربائية
يجب أن يكون لدى المسافرين المزيد من الخيارات عند
الطلب أكثر من أي وقت مضى ،
ولكن لضمان أن كل هذا النقل
يحول عالمنا لمخططي حضري أفضل ،
يجب أولاً النظر في
مرآة الرؤية الخلفية ،
علينا أن نلقي نظرة نقدية
على الأخطاء التي ارتكبناها.
القرن الماضي
وخاطب هؤلاء بشكل واضح ،
أود أن أقول بطريقة علمية
يتم تعريف المدن بالطرق التي يتم
تعريفها حرفيًا على أنها أسطح للمركبات
ولكن في أوائل القرن العشرين ،
تمت مشاركة الطرق والشوارع مع المشاة ،
وأنا أعلم ما الذي تفكر فيه أن السيارات
ظهرت  كان من الحتمي أن القاموس
لم يكن مخطئًا أبدًا
ولكن إعطاء هذه الأماكن العامة
للسيارات كان في الواقع
فعلًا من هذا القبيل يرجع جزئيًا إلى رغبة الناس
في التحرك بشكل مختلف في السيارات
لكنها تأثرت أيضًا بشكل كبير
بالصناعات التي كانت تحاول التحرك في
اتجاهات معينة من شأنها زيادة
مبيعاتها
طوال القرن العشرين ،
غالبًا ما أعطى المخططون الحضريون الأولوية للسيارات
مما أدى إلى الزحف العمراني المروري
وحتى عزل
هذا الشارع الذي كان
يربط في الأصل أجزاء مختلفة من المدينة
طريق أو حتى طريق سريع أسوأ من ذلك ،
حيث فصل كل شيء
، وهذا يعني أنه
يمكن الآن فصل حيين تمامًا
وليس لهما علاقة ببعضهما البعض.
من الناحية النظرية ، يجرون اختبارًا في الكويت ،
يفضل الكويتيون قيادة العديد من الطرق السريعة
والشوارع الرئيسية ، وقد أدى ذلك حقًا
إلى تقليل
الأماكن العامة والأحياء المنفصلة
في عام 2009 ، حيث قالت الأمم المتحدة إن
جميع الطرق في الكويت جاهزة تمامًا
أو ستصبح قريبًا بكامل طاقتها
المحلية  كانت المنافذ الإخبارية تبلغ عن
مشكلة أكبر
لذلك كان علينا تقديم شيء ما يمكننا دائمًا
بناء المزيد من الطرق السريعة ، لكن
هذا مجرد حل قصير المدى
، حيث تعمل الخطة الرئيسية على تغيير أنه في عام 2017
شرعت الكويت في خطة رئيسية جديدة لعام
لإعادة تصميم أحياء اليوم مع
وضع تكنولوجيا الغد في الاعتبار
أكثر من مائة مخطط و  قام المهندسون المعماريون
بشكل أساسي بإنشاء لوحة قماشية فارغة
لإزالة السيارات من الشوارع حتى
يكونوا جاهزين لخيارات جديدة عندما
تصبح متاحة ،
على سبيل المثال ، كان هذا الطريق مغطى بالسيارات مرة واحدة
ولكن تم الآن تخصيصه للمشاة
لتمهيد الطريق لبدائل عبور متعددة
يمكننا  استخدام مشاركة الميكروفون ومشاركة
المركبات المستقلة ومن ثم حول
نظام مترو أن هذا المترو سيكون به محطات ذكية
مجهزة بمجموعة من الخيارات
لمساعدة المسافرين على الوصول إلى وجهتهم النهائية ،
لذا تستخدم الخطة الرئيسية تحليل البيانات
لبناء وإنشاء
مدينة مناسبة
لها  الناس لاستخدام وسائط النقل المختلفة
تقترح الخطة الرئيسية تحويل
أكثر من 200 صهيل  من الواضح أن النبلاء في جميع أنحاء
البلاد
والهدف الرئيسي هو تحسين
السفر
ولكن الهدف الأكبر هو سهولة
هذه الحركة لدفع الدولة بأكملها
إلى الأمام من خلال جذب الاستثمار.
لا يمكن أن يكون هذا المركز المالي الجديد في الكويت وكالجاري بعيدًا عن بعضهما البعض ،
لكن يبدو أنهما يشتركان في شيء
مشترك من
خلال التخطيط الاستباقي للعبور في الغد ،
فهم يأملون في تسخير قوتهم
لخلق مستقبل أكثر إشراقًا والذي
يطرح السؤال هل
ستجعل كل هذه التكنولوجيا عالمنا
مكان أفضل